temperature right now is about minus 12
degrees so it's not exactly what you
call perfect weather for a dip but
that's what this group of Russians are
about to do epiphany marks the time when
Jesus Christ was baptized into the
church and Russians believe that by
dunking themselves into icy water they
will wash away all their sins cock-thumb
she says it was very cold which is
unsurprising really now something that
has become more and more popular since
the fall of the Soviet Union
particularly in recent years with the
rise of the Orthodox Church new partner
everyone's saying it's not cold now a
priest here has blessed the water so
people believe it dip won't make them
sick some even think that the freezing
water is positively good for their
health I have met d'italia who has
persuaded me somewhat reluctantly to
give it a go this is my first time I
didn't want to take my coat off um but
let's go they dumped oh you go first
she's going to show me what to do
it's really cold out here Natalia had
given me some advice she told me to take
my towel off and just get straight in
because it's really cold and Yassa
in what the oven she's telling me to 90
times it's like knives cutting into my
skin oh my goodness me actually they're
right the water is quite warm right now
then I need a towel shade you loser me
killer so you don't seem do this is
she's saying that it's good not just for
your soul but also your body and that
she's saying everyone should do it
actually is quite invigorating but right
now I just really need a warm some warm
clothes and a cup of tea